ha sido un mensaje corto que ha leído
con cara de tensión rodeado de algunos
de sus aliados y llama la atención
evidentemente que no haya felicitado a
Lula que no haya reconocido su derrota
pero también llaman la atención otras
cosas que no se saben pero que se
suponen y que están creando mucha
polémica en los bastidores porque tardó
tanto hay dos teorías según el ex
ministro de seguridad pública él podría
haber estado Esperando que las protestas
de Los camioneros pudiesen extenderse al
resto de sus 58 millones de Seguidores
para intentar una especie de
insurrección de hecho el en su discurso
ha dicho que siempre son bienvenidas las
manifestaciones pacíficas y alguna forma
ha justificado lo que hemos visto desde
el día de ayer además ha dicho también
hoy por la mañana se ha reunido con
Valdemar costanetto que es el presidente
del partido liberal para de alguna forma
negociar su salida del gobierno hay que
recordar que Lula por ejemplo tiene una
fundación que le respalda bolsonaro
siempre vencido la camisa de antisistema
en sus 30 años de vida política ha
pasado por nueve partidos ahora estaba
en el partido liberal él no tiene un
salario y ni siquiera tienen en este
momento abogados que puedan defenderle
en los más de 50 procesos que le
aguardan entre otras cosas por haber
interferido de la Policía Federal por
haber difundido fake news noticias
falsas de la campaña electoral y por
haber asociado la vacuna contra el covid
19 a la alzira durante la pandemia estas
son solo algunas de las frentes abiertas
que tiene en este momento bolsonaro por
esta razón se especula que él estuviese
negociando con el partido liberal que
este año ha elegido la mayor bancada al
mayor grupo parlamentario con 99
integrantes un sueldo probablemente una
casa Unas condiciones
digamos cómodas a perder digamos su
inmunidad a dejar al dejar el cargo de
presidente hoy podemos decir
oficialmente que se cierra la era
bolsonaro empieza ahora una difícil
transición en la que el equipo tiene una
tiene que hacerse con el estado de las
cuentas públicas el estado de los
presupuestos para poder por fin trazar
una política económica viable de Cara a
los próximos cuatro años